[Music]
check out J Lo's new rock feature and
super bright and I feel like we we both
feel like we're just beginning Jennifer
Lopez and longtime beau Alex Rodriguez
made things official on Saturday that be
coupled both instagramming this
beautiful sparkler on her ring finger a
rod captioning the pic she said yes and
JLo with a plethora of hearts I mean
we've been having a lot of fun and I've
been enjoying just spending time with
her kids her kids
jewelry expert Catherine money tells et
she estimates Jennifer's stunning
engagement ring to be over 1 million
dollars adding that the ring appears to
feature a 12 to 15 carat emerald cut
diamond we both are so happy about our
lives right now the singer and former
baseball pro began dating in February of
2017 we complement each other in a
beautiful way and I couldn't have asked
for a better partner in this Jennifer
told Ellen DeGeneres during an
appearance on her show in April 2017
that the pair connected one day while
they were separately having lunch saying
that for some reason she felt like
tapping him on the shoulder and they
started chatting about life in Los
Angeles Alex then reached out to ask her
on a date the couple made their red
carpet debut at the Met Gala in May 2017
and had been inseparable ever since we
just like to keep it simple anything
with the kids
anything with a movie chocolate chip
cookies you know she's great she's fun
and like we say she's like everyone's
boss around here we have one boss and I
report to all the girls it's really max
and I and we have the ladies are crazy
the governing body at the home the newly
engaged parrot spoke on multiple
occasions about how their kids from
separate marriages
JLo's Max and Amy
and Alex's daughters Natasha and Ella
have gotten close I've learned so much
from her in such a short period of time
my daughter's lover she's a great role
model she's a Latina woman for both born
in this great city of New York and it's
fun to give back in red what I like most
about Jennifer's anything she does in
business or an entertainment where's her
Ben dennerlein is always a double bottom
oh she always wants to get back to
congratulations to the happy couple
we're beginning a new chapter of our
lives in every way and it's it's
exciting
[Applause]